Now the topic of women has become number
two after jihad and Islam was spelled by
the initially it was number one. So if
you read my book on misconceptions about
Islam if you read the old edition the
topics of women on top now they are
second in order.
I remember
in 1994
I gave a talk on women's rights in Islam
modernizing or outdated and I remember
that was my second big public talk. The
first was Quran and modern science
conflict of consiliation and this was my
second talk in 1994.
I'm talking about a big public gathering
and I gave a talk on women's rights in
Islam modernizing outdated.
If you agree with how the western media
portrays Islam, you have no option but
to agree it's outdated.
But today
let us understand
the true
women's rights Islam. Therefore, the
topic of my talk today is
the true
gender equality
and Islamic solution.
Before we develop topic, I would like to
make a few points clear that today the
Muslim population is more than 25%. It's
about more than 26%.
More than 1/5ifth of the world
population today, more than 2 billion
human beings today, every fifth person
in the world today is a Muslim.
But
some
Muslim societies
are close to Islam while the others are
far away from Islam.
As far as women's rights in Islam is
concerned, you should not judge women
rights in Islam by looking at an
individual Muslim or the Muslim society.
It should be judged by analyzing the
authentic sources in Islam.
The authentic sources in Islam are
number one the glorious Quran and number
two the authentic a hadith the say
hadith of our beloved prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
the sayings and actions
the authentic sayings and action of our
beloved prophet wasallam.
So to understand Islam,
you should analyze the Quran and the say
not look at individual Muslims or what
Muslims do or what the Muslim society
does.
There may be sometimes
where scholarly opinions regarding
women's rights may differ
and sometimes it's due to quoting some
verse of the Quran and neglecting the
other verses of the Quran on the topic.
If we analyze Quran as a whole, then
many a times the reference of one aspect
of the woman's rights is given somewhere
else also in the Quran or in the
authentic hadith. Never will the Quran
contradict itself.
Neither the authentic hadith contradict
itself nor would the Quran contradict
the authentic hadith.
So if you analyze the Quran as a whole,
most of these differences along with the
say hadith they can be resolved.
It's the duty of every Muslim man or
woman that he should seek he should seek
the pleasure of Allah subhana wa t'ala.
His main test in this world is to follow
the commandments of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala. Seek his pleasure. He should not
do it for fame or for popularity or for
personal gains.